er will es noch einmal wissen Recep type
Erdogan lässt sich vom Parteivolk als
größter Herrscher der modernen Türkei
feiern im nächsten Jahr sind Wahlen und
die Republik feiert ihren hundertsten
Geburtstag da möchte Erdogan den
bisherigen Vater aller Türken Kemal
Atatürk endgültig als Lichtgestalt
Ablösen der Mann der die Türkei stark
gemacht hat der mit seinem Militär seine
Regeln durchsetzt auch und vor allem
gleich jenseits der Grenze in Syrien
[Musik]
hat jedes Recht dazu für ihre eigene
Sicherheit innerhalb und außerhalb ihrer
Grenzen zu sorgen
niemand kann sich uns dabei in den Weg
stellen
niemand kann uns daran hindern unser
Recht auf Sicherheit durchzusetzen
was das heißt konnten Menschen im
kurdisch kontrollierten noch zu ihren
gleich nach dem Bombenanschlag von
Istanbul erleben 400 Ziele griff die
hochgerüstete türkische Armee an mehr
als 30 Menschen kamen ums Leben auch ein
weiterer Einmarsch ist geplant
so Gott will werden wir Sie bald schon
alle mit unseren Panzern unseren
Soldaten und der Hilfe unserer Freunde
ausrotten
bereits viermal ist die Türkei in Syrien
einmarschiert sie kontrolliert weite
Teile des Nordens Erdogans Gegner hier
die kurdischen Milizen entlang der
türkischen Grenze der Ukraine Krieg so
glauben Beobachter hat jetzt einiges
verändert
einem Mächte Amerika und die Russen sind
im Moment auf den Krieg in der Ukraine
konzentriert und sind sehr viel weniger
bereit militärisch politisches Kapital
in die Waagschale zu werfen für Nord
Syrien was unter Umständen einen
Unterschied machen könnte
erdogan ist am Drücker die NATO bettelt
um seine Zustimmung zum Beitritt
Schwedens und Finnlands Russland braucht
ihn als letztes Tor zur Welt die
Fixierung auf Eroberungen in Syrien hat
aber noch ganz andere handfeste Gründe
denn was die Jubelbilder im Stadion
verdecken sollen der starke Mann steckt
in einem nie da gewesenen Umfrage tief
und die Gründe sind hausgemacht sie
haben auch mit Syrien zu tun
wir sind in Essen Jod einem Istanbuler
Arbeiterviertel Ausländeranteil 30
Prozent wer hier nachfragt was die
türkische Bevölkerung von fast 4
Millionen syrischen Flüchtlingen im Land
hält bekommt deutlicher Antworten
egal wo du hingehst die sind überall und
den geht es eindeutig besser als uns
während ich nicht mal weiß wie die
Zukunft meiner Kinder aussieht was soll
ich tun
ich zahle 4er Miete letztes Jahr waren
es 600 die Vermieter wollen nur noch
reicher Ausländer und Dollar und ich
weiß nicht wie ich über die Runden
kommen soll staatliche Hilfe bekomme ich
keine die Syrer aber schon
die Wirtschaftskrise mit 85 Prozent
Inflation hoher Arbeitslosigkeit trifft
die Menschen hier am härtesten und kaum
jemand macht Erdogans verfehlte
Währungspolitik für die
notverantwortlich stattdessen wächst die
Ausländerfeindlichkeit die Schuld am
Elend wird bei den Flüchtlingen gesucht
ich mag die Syrer nicht seit die
hergekommen sind haben wir keine Ruhe
mehr die Mieten sind gestiegen und die
Lebensmittelpreise sind gestiegen
ich wähle trotzdem Erdogan dann wird es
laut
[Musik]
wie kannst du nach all den Ärger noch
ernsthaft sagen du willst den
die anstehende Wahl so viel ist klar
wird kein Selbstläufer für Erdogan die
Stimmung ist aufgeheizt in Essen Jod
macht sich unter Syrern ein Klima der
Angst breit sie vermeiden Gespräche auf
Arabisch in der Öffentlichkeit arabische
Werbung an den Läden haben sie entfernt
bloß nicht auffallen auch Gewalt gegen
Flüchtlinge nimmt im ganzen Land zu
es ist immer noch Krieg bei uns
Amerikaner sind da Russen Iraner wir
wollen alle zurück aber nicht solange
der Krieg herrscht
der Druck wächst eine halbe Million
Syrer sein schon zurück in die Heimat
behauptet die Regierung freiwillig wie
es heißt
Menschenrechtsorganisationen werfen
Ankara vor mit Druck und Misshandlungen
diese Freiwilligkeit erzwungen zu haben
trotzdem nutzt die Opposition vor allem
die Rechten Nationalisten die
ausländerfeindliche Stimmung im Erdogan
weiter vor sich herzutreiben
[Musik]
unser Land ist zu einem flüchtlingsdepot
geworden durch die Regierung zum
Mülleimer Europas und all das haben wir
Erdogan und der AKP zu verdanken
Europa so der Experte einer
regierungsnahen Denkfabrik sei heilfroh
das Problem der Türkei zu überlassen
aber das könnte sich rächen wir haben
eine Untersuchung durchgeführt 60
Prozent der syrischen Flüchtlinge in der
Türkei möchten nicht zurück nach Syrien
sie möchten stattdessen von der Türkei
in die EU und Deutschland wird als Ziel
Nummer eins genannt
noch sechs Monate bis zur Wahl trotz
Wirtschaftskrise Bombenanschlags und
Angriffen in Syrien und Irak ist er
zuversichtlich auch im hundertsten Jahr
der türkischen Republik wird es nur
einen Mann an der Spitze geben Erdogan